I've started this video at least 5-6
times keep on deleting what I've
recorded I'm missing the point of what
it is that I'm doing I have to commit
new video let's do this let's do this
now hello and welcome back to YouTube
midlife crisis week starring me Charlie
McDonnell the crazy person in your
internet yesterday I mentioned the fact
that I work on videos every single day
but what I didn't tell you is that
because I am a nerd I actually have a
chart to back that statement up it's the
green one
this is mature that I've bought there it
is this is my don't break the chain
videos charts don't break the chain is a
Productivity tip that I learned from
Jerry Seinfeld well I mean I didn't I
didn't learn it from Jerry Seinfeld I
learnt it from the internet
and the internet learnt it from Jerry
Seinfeld the idea is that if you have a
thing you need to do and you need to do
it all the time you give yourself a
minimum amount of work required so with
videos I work on them at least half an
hour every day and as you can see here
today is 19th I haven't got max yet
because I have been working on videos
for half an hour yet as well as working
on videos I also have one for exercising
which I do three times a week and I have
one for film writing as well which I'll
get to in a second to me this don't
break the chain things been one of the
best decisions I've made it a long time
because where before if I found myself
in a day where I just didn't feel like
doing anything I would just not do
anything I'd just play games and watch
TV and that would be my whole day but
nowadays if I don't feel like doing
anything I do get at least one hours
worth of work done per day and although
one hour doesn't seem like that much
work it is obviously better than nothing
and if you keep it up for you know a
month and a half as I have been so far
it does add up for example my film
writing you might remember a little
while ago I made a video in which I
talked about my new year's resolutions
the first one do more exercise obviously
on top of that baby the second one was
do more nice things for other people
which I'm also still doing pretty well
and the third one was to write a feature
film which is oh I I haven't been
writing my feature film I'm sorry please
let me explain let me just show you my
film writing charts you see that you see
how all of those X's are filled up I
have been working on a film I have every
single day half an hour at least I just
haven't been working on my feature film
I have been working on something
you oh yeah I've been working on a short
film is so disappointing I was talking
to my friend Michael Michael Aranda and
he has a bachelor's degree in film
writing something I don't know he has
more degrees than I do and I told him
that I was writing a feature film and he
said and then I said really I told him
said didn't you make it short film first
and I said yeah I know but I told the
Internet I was gonna write a feature and
then I thought about it and thought yeah
I should probably do a short film but
good news I've done like three drafts of
a script this is the first time I've
ever finished like a screenplay for
anything so I'm actually progressing
that's the good thing I'm doing it I'm
doing a film short film oh he's gone
cold now the end I'm so not used to
doing vlogs man I want to end it I want
it to be better no I have to upload it
that's what this is you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool